ahora caminan juntos pero hasta hace
unos años estos jóvenes no podían estar
en un mismo lugar Arthur pertenecía a
los Latin Kings Jenny a los trinitarios
dos de las grandes bandas juveniles
violentas que existen en España eran
enemigos pero con historias similares
bueno en este momento yo necesitaba lo
que era un apoyo familiar y mi padre era
maltratador y mi madre trataba de darme
lo mejor Pero yo yo me sentía abandonado
y yo cogí Y vi un refugio en ello de
poderme esconder de poderme sentir
apoyado entre mis padres había muchas
peleas discusiones entonces en casa yo
no me sentía bien yo prefería estar
fuera de casa entonces fue allí cuando
yo les conocía Y ellos me dijeron ahora
vamos a hacer tu familia entraron a
estas bandas con 14 y 13 años
respectivamente ahora la edad de inicio
es cada vez más temprana por eso la
Policía Nacional enfoca sus esfuerzos de
prevención en las escuelas
hablando del alumnado a los padres a los
profesores contándoles la realidad del
problema que es pertenecer ingresar o
simplemente simpatizar con algún tipo de
banda juvenil no en el cual puedes
destrozar prácticamente una vida y toda
de su entorno
Jenny Arthur salieron de estos grupos
violentos bajo el amparo de la iglesia
una de las pocas opciones de escape que
no trae consigo represalias
cuando tienen problemas y son presos que
les visita es un pastor es un sacerdote
hay un respeto Ellos saben que cuando
necesitan ayuda pueden venir de hecho
nos buscan jóvenes que Son miembros
activos de bandas para desahogarse esta
iglesia ha ayudado a unos 300 jóvenes a
desvincularse de la violencia sin
embargo solo en Madrid hay unos 2.500
pandilleros activos un negocio que
además mueve casi 10 millones de euros
anuales